We’ve all been there, you’ve just won
the lottery, and you’re kicking back in
the hot tub, indulging in your favourite beverage.
Then, all of a sudden it’s gone.
Your alarm clock rudely awakens you and you
come to the sudden realisation that your life
is considerably less glamorous than in your
dreams.
Oh bollocks.
But then something strange happens, five minutes
passes by and you’ve forgotten most of,
if not all of your dream and that’s if you’re
lucky, sometimes we have dreams we’re not
even aware of, because we can’t remember
even having them, after we’ve awoken.
Why is this?
Why do we so easily forget our dreams?
Let’s find out.
The brain is the last major mystery of the
human body.
There are so many aspects of the brain that
continuously baffle scientists and one of
those is sleep.
Scientists aren’t even one hundred per cent
sure why we even need sleep.
So when it comes to understanding dreams,
we’re still very much in the dark.
We have many theories of course.
One of the most popular theories is that when
we sleep our brains are filtering through
the day’s memories and deciding which ones
are important enough to keep permanently and
which to ditch.
Scientists think dreams are a visual representation
of this process.
Based on that theory it makes sense that in
order to understand dreams further we should
study the two parts of the brain that are
larger responsible for processing memories.
Those are the hippocampus and the neocortex.
And that’s exactly what researchers at the
California Institute of Technology did.
First let’s talk about the hippocampus,
which you may be surprised to know, is not
a college campus for hippos it’s actually
named after its resemblance to a seahorse.
This is the part of our brains where memories
are formed.
However, it’s thought that during sleep
these memories get transferred to the outer
layer of our brain, the neocortex, where they
are permanently stored.
Think of it like a digital camera.
The hippocampus is the camera’s sensor;
the neocortex is the memory card.
For a memory to be transferred from the hippocampus
to the neocortex the two parts of the brain
have to be connected via neurons, which are
responsible for transmitting information around
our brains.
If your brain were the Internet then your
neurons would be the routers.
The hippocampus and the neocortex do this
by firing electrical signals from their neurons
at exactly the same time, several times per
second.
Imagine the two parts of your brain are having
a conversation about the events of the day
i.e. your memories.
When they both fire their neurons at the same
time and they are in sync we know they are
communicating with each other.
Scientists call this “neural chatter”.
Researchers at Caltech used brand new technology
to listen in to these two parts of the brain
in rats, whilst they were sleeping.
They found that whilst the rats were in a
stage of the sleep cycle known as slow-wave
sleep, more commonly referred to as “deep
sleep”, the hippocampus and neocortex where
perfectly in sync.
Their neurons were firing at the same time.
From this we can presume that the two parts
of the brain were talking to each other and
memories were being recorded.
But here’s where dreams come in.
During the slow-wave sleep phase we don’t
have any dreams, this is known as a dreamless
sleep state.
The researchers then did the same thing whilst
the rats were in the rapid eye movement or
R.E.M.
sleep stage.
What they observed, once and for all, answered
why we have a hard time remembering our dreams.
During the R.E.M.
sleep stage the hippocampus and neocortex
were still firing their neurons, but not at
the same time.
They were no longer in-sync.
To put it in other words, they were still
having conversations, but not with each other.
This means during R.E.M.
sleep memories don’t get recorded to our
brain’s databank, the neocortex and R.E.M.
sleep is when the majority of our dreams occur.
So the memories of our dreams are still being
created, they’re just not being stored permanently.
We remember only very faint aspects of our
dreams, because very occasionally the neurons
might, by chance, fire at the same time, but
the majority of the time they don’t.
Some people believe this is because dreams
are non-essential to life; they’re no more
than a by-product of the creation of new memories
during our sleep.
So what’s the point in remembering them?
They don’t serve a purpose.
But for whatever reason, we don’t remember
our dreams, simply because during a certain
stage of our sleep, two very important parts
of our brain, which are both responsible for
memory, don’t get on with each other very
well.
To be honest, it’s probably for the best;
some of the weird-ass stuff we do in our dreams
is definitely best forgotten.